mary o mio dio ciao ciao
che bello vederti ma da quanto tempo ma
lasciami il tuo numero così ci andiamo a bere
un caffè insieme che ci raccontiamo un
po le ultime news che bello vedermi
che bello vedermi ma se non ci
sopportiamo é dalla seconda media che ci
odiamo ma cosa stai dicendo
ma quanto sei falsa e poi il caffè te lo
puoi pure prendere da sola ma chi c'ha voglia di prendere un caffè con te
ma sai che proprio
l'altro giorno ti stavo pensando ho detto
ma chissà che fine ha fatto Otta certo si si
segnatelo 349 mari sono ormai settimane
che ci penso io non posso più esserti
amico io provo qualcosa per te voglio
voglio condividere la quotidianità fare
nuove esperienze voglio magari un giorno
anche avere una famiglia
devo saperlo tu cosa provi per me
immaginavo che sarebbe arrivato questo
momento per te
edo provo tanta pena ma tantissima non mi
piaci non mi sei mai piaciuto e mai mi
piacerai edo io non vorrei ferire i
tuoi sentimenti ma per me la nostra
amicizia è la cosa più importante e almeno
per il momento preferirei insomma non
cambiare le cose tra di noi
poi un giorno beh mai dire mai
non si può mai sapere nella vita amo ma
sei sicura che mi sta bene non mi fa un
pó grassa lo vedo un pó pacchiano su di
me si ti fa grassa e si é pacchiano ma
siamo in ritardo
se io ti dico che questo vestito non ti sta
bene tu ci impiegherai altre due ore per
sceglierne un altro oppure mi dirai che
non vieni più e io a ballare da solo non
ci vado quindi amo ma stai scherzando
sei pazzesca cioé favolosa oh è hai presente
dolce e gabbana uguali mari io non so più
quello che provo penso che ci serve del
tempo per capire quello che vogliamo
quello di cui abbiamo bisogno
ci serve una pausa tu cosa ne pensi
cosa ne penso
io penso che tu abbia un'altra eh si non me la conti giusta cos'è questa storia
della pausa ma da quando ma una pausa
per cosa poi una pausa è soltanto una
scusa per lasciarsi a rate non scappi eh
non mi lasci così no mi dispiace
tu sei mio tu non vai da nessuna parte che io la pausa non la voglio non l'accetto
sì sì la la penso come te sono d'accordo
hai ragiona non dirmi che ti piace
questo cesso
no non mi piace io lo amo pazzamente lui
è tutta la mia vita io lo sogno la notte
mi sveglia al mattino e lo penso io lo
voglio sposare lui sarà mio
un giorno sarà mio ma ovviamente no ti pare
allora amore com'era la cena coi miei secondo me é stata una serata pazzesca e ti é
piaciuto l'arrosto di papá e i complimenti
della mamma sincera é stata una serata
di merda tua mamma mi sta sulle palle é una
vecchia arpia continuava a parlare della tua
ex elogiandola ma ti sembra il caso
veramente di cattivo gusto
tuo papá non sa cucinare e quell'arrosto
faceva schifo e non l'ho mangiato tutto
perché mentre giocavate a carte e
guardavate che i filmini di natale io l'ho
buttato nel cammino sincera é stata la
serata più bella della mia vita amore i
tuoi sono veramente fantastici mi hanno
fatto veramente sentire a casa
cioè non mi sono mai sentita a disagio per tutta la cena poi l'arrosto l'arrosto
cosa non era guarda luca cosa mi ha
appena scritto quanto è tenero è o non è
il ragazzo perfetto
beh se con perfetto intendi che ti fa le
corna con tutta la scuola si è perfetto
ah e per la cronaca ci ha provato anche
con me
meglio single che cornute ma che
carino che tenero avercelo un ragazzo
così quanto ti invidio anche se vi ho
detto di preparare per oggi pascoli
montale ungaretti
stamattina mi sono svegliato con una
voglia di sentire qualcosa su
leopardi quindi mi parli di leopardi e te
pareva
ho studiato tutto tranne leopardi e lui cosa mi chiede adesso come faccio
facciamo una cosa se questo video arriva a 60.000 like girerò la seconda parte e
ripasserò leopardi e mi raccomando
iscrivetevi al canale e cliccate sulla
campanella che trovate vicino al tasto
d'iscrizione non dimenticatevelo e
soprattutto seguitemi su tutti gli
altri social
instagram facebook e tiktok adesso
provo a inventarmi qualcosa ehm giacomo
leopardi
sì allora